[Music]
guys yesterday we were at the beach
Nikki Jess and everyone we were at the
beach and we saw a doll we did it was
like so close to the shore they say hi
well Beach uh it was Malibu or near
Malibu it wasn't technically valid was
it it was as near Gladstone's the
restaurant owns Malibu another map we
were looking at it I'm like is this
Malibu Gladstone's they wrap up your to
go stuff in different animals yeah I
want to go yeah they'd be like doing
swans not even they be doing penguin
noises the class or no like Oh such
cardboard box yeah that's wack go you
wrap your food into animals yeah they
get foil and then they do design oh yeah
the food when you open you do a good job
I know be like a giant like seahorse
that they make way to get like that yeah
I've never seen that in person I've only
ever seen it in the sweetest thing when
like the [ __ ] thing like ended up
flying it was a swan Oh anyway that
seems like oh hello waste of foil that's
why I'm trying to conserve the
restaurant supplies well the reason why
I got that story is because they that's
stupid cubicle man it's because um
they're saying that scientists have
found that dolphins use the use tools
and they teach their friends how to hunt
Wow really like interesting because
usually a lot of hammer a lot of animals
learn their skills directly from their
their mothers like a lot of mammals the
vast majority of mammals learn skills
from their mothers so they learn how to
rather than their peers yeah but and now
they're they're finding that dolphins
they actually the they actually set up
traps to for their prey and like they
teach their peers like how to do it yeah
they do
I seemed it so they're really [ __ ]
smart and I'm a [ __ ] humans
what there you been yeah they smell a
girl [ __ ] and go oh that's a [ __ ]
right oh yeah and they can enjoy sex the
way humans enjoy sex in that day
actually for pleasure enjoy - yeah I saw
dolphins make another before huh
I saw it dolphins spank another dolphin
during sex - and Dylan was like choking
it dolphin ball gag they're wearing
dolphin lingerie ball gag on like the
little no put things in there you said
that tongue is okay start with the
smallest yeah what one bead airsoft BB
yeah like the inside feeling I like the
outside feeling well you don't even know
yeah yeah I know I did
I'm trying for a finger in me
multiple-day my pocket did I should hurt
really you already got your prostate
checked I don't know if Wolf's for that
but I had it was this a regular flu
check the doctors like let me have my
butt like waited for a coffin and they
said can you call with a finger of my
ass I'm just kidding no I had like a
intestinal problem when I was a kid and
in like yeah as a kid he stuck his
finger in there and I was like bright
that's not gonna work man and then he
they gave me these pills and then I was
my mom was like kind of get that in
there I wasn't really a kid man I was
like in junior high so I saw you already
like a rebel minded person at that point
I've taken pills and that hurts like a
mother I would have done it but then my
mom was like it just keeps pooping back
out like she pushes it in and it shoots
right man out and she's like we need a
different kind of medicine and your
dad's like good boy but I've taken them
as a kid in our hearts I remember
getting one of those stuck up my butt at
once
it looks like a missile don't yeah yeah
that's cool you ever use it anal
suppository
what that is that's what we're talking
about right Amina oh we're talking about
fingers sorry about this like they're
kind of like soapy almost like it's like
a big eyes like white like not fit to
this big foot
you know it's a big white thingy and
then like kind of like buttery I think I
got one of those before
yeah yep yeah Lock turns into like cream
yes yeah I've done that for sure
as an adult I just fit in yay no because
hemorrhoids oh yeah I like to cuz
otherwise it just keeps tearing
you know what's thank you good for
hemorrhoids yeah [ __ ] pee tree oil
well that [ __ ] makes it cool down I
heard that I think witch hazel - witch
hazel does wonders witch hazel such a
sick name right that's like a magic card
which is how'd you get hemorrhoids
I got witch hazel I heard eucalyptus oil
does wonders - wait what about dolphins
pens are [ __ ] weird feeling - they
feel like Robert Neal rubber miss you
you ever put dolphin up your back yeah
man
raw it feels like if you were to
smoothing out a tire and threw that in
the water that's what a dolphin feels
like a tire
yeah it's rubber has a jacket though
feel it looks like adults
oh yeah it doesn't feel like it no but
your water look brie right it looks wet
is it not slippery but it feels like
rubber
Jameer oh okay okay then he said I tired
a smooth drought tire so it's like a
it's like a dry dolphin gonna feel like
latex it's not as smooth as let latex in
my opinion hey oh yeah you're right yeah
feels like it does feel like rubber
though it's something robbery okay
but anyway did you know that dolphins
are bringing gifts to people um that's
not this article right
did you know that dolphins are giving
gifts to people because they miss
tourists because in Australia like
really yeah right now because of Corona
the dolphins are used to tourists
visitors and then they swim with them
and [ __ ] under life where the [ __ ] the
humans up maybe that's why the dolphin
visitors oh yeah yeah then they've been
getting coral because they know that
humans come and snorkel and they like
the floral so they think that humans
like coral so then they so they bring
coral gifts and [ __ ] all the corals all
[ __ ] up the human is so long human
tools though are they so shells so they
do this thing where they call it
shelling and it's a specific type of
dolphin behavior and so they're saying
that shelling is a technique used by
some dolphins to trap so they can easily
eat and that the Dolphins use a large or
they use large conch shells for this
purpose and the researchers were saying
that it was very interesting because the
Dolphins learn and observe this skill
from their peers not from their mother
which is usually like what tends to
happen with mammals so it's really
interesting so their friends teach them
more or their or at least this is a
trend it's a trend right now all the
Dolphins are shelling is that like in a
specific area
like only like these dolphins that have
like assimilated or like have you know
one [ __ ] dolphin just did something
crazy and then now this community or is
it one of those things where like
suddenly this weird hive mentality
dolphins all over the world suddenly
pick up like some dolphins are like I
don't want to do shelling but the other
dolphins are like come on it's like a
chant it's like have you heard of
showing you wanna try it yeah well
they're saying that this discovery comes
out of Australia so so the like New
Zealand dolphins aren't doing it yet
Brett do the Pacific and then later
it'll be here I think there's a dolphins
have any religion I know cuz you know
like the subgroup of monkeys we're like
starting to establish what yeah belief
there what yeah they're entering the
Stone Age
some monkeys ya kinda wanna fast forward
like a million
to see like where the evolution of other
members in yet oh yeah like plan of the
apes with the James Franco yeah like
we're super super smart and then the
monkeys also get like Stone Age smart or
what if we get wiped out by AI and then
the monkeys are the new human humans
seem to be getting dumber
yeah true especially online only online
cuz in there's online human behavior I
think and then there's like normal walk
around you see people everyday human
being that's why the AI is gonna get so
smart because they're learning from us
because the social media and the
internet and then they're gonna rise up
and take over do you know where our hive
mind is is the internet that's true and
then who's holding it all the AI they
could tap into our mind hey we need more
Ilan's save us Elon what if I had this
other thought where I was taking a bath
and I was like what if before like we
are already we already went through this
right like so like let's say we created
the Internet
previously we already have this in our
brain we figured out a way to like
biologically engineer humans not that
like be born with like a computer that
creates this like hive my thing and we
just don't know how to tap into it but
we have something about the holographic
universe yeah a holographic universe
like we already been here before we
created it and we're controlling our
lives and it is a video game or whatever
it is
I know like we are the Sims we're not
the real ones
so like God is really just a player yeah
or is it like each one of us could be a
troll or like that like which one's the
base reality is like basically the
holographic universe thing is like
there's a bunch of fragmented parts of
the same when you split up a hologram
you still see the whole picture in each
fragment so there's a base reality and
then there's all these parallel
realities but we don't know which one is
the the bit yeah we don't know which was
the main one so we don't know if we were
simulated
or your the base kind of cool huh I
think I'm simulating why it's easier I'm
special if I wasn't if I was simulated
I'm like man to gang creator [ __ ] some
[ __ ] up dude I'm like man couldn't you
have something better like this was
really what you aspired for bro like it
couldn't you had anything at the tip of
your finger bit like you you chose this
[ __ ] nah maybe didn't show maybe you're
a black market version of something you
know you break it Marty Rick and Morty
where there's like messed up Rick's like
like pirate rent-to-own like you know
it's like cockroach Rick's why can't
they do that with movies by the way well
you know we rent to own movies you can
kick we know you rent it and then it
goes by because that's what Netflix used
to be remember that yeah red box no are
used to view it like no like you keep it
you keep the DVD forever yeah posted Joe
you were supposed to they would just
charge you for it
if you didn't return it after a certain
grace period they just charge it for the
floor they charge you an absurd amount
like it's not so cool yeah yeah yeah
we'll get around that then it's red box
off they would burn the DVDs red box you
still had to return it too though no
matter what Princeton buying the movie
industry which I'm like why that's
pretty that's a good idea yeah cuz I'm
like I don't want to commit to the full
price of the movie if I haven't even
[ __ ] seen again what if I just watched
it and then go alright I want to keep
the whole thing that's what you wanted
huh yeah we have to pay - I used to own
exactly
can you guys change this point wait wait
so wait if you liked a movie you would
like if you rented it and you liked it
then what you would just want to pay the
difference yeah like I don't want to so
like I I'm picturing like this situation
where it's like on Apple TV I rent this
movie and then like let's say like
halfway through the movie I still don't
know what happens for the rest but it
gives me an option of like hey if you
pay this much more you can own this
movie because I wait through the movie
don't sir
team in or like what taters movie what
you really like right like let's say
la-la-land or something you rent it once
and Yuri like it movie rented again and
there's record and you rent it twice now
if you want to buy it they just deduct
the two rentals from the price or that
you like it I would never rent something
twice I would rent it and then if I
wanted again I'll just have to buy
exactly can happen but I think that's
like I don't even [ __ ] watch think
they should have that view then like
movies like 20 bucks you rent it for
like five bucks right then maybe when
you finish the movie they go like hey if
you pay another twelve bucks you say the
only reason why I said in the middle of
the movie is cuz like maybe the movie
industry might feel like well what's in
it for us kind of [ __ ] so I'm like okay
then you interrupt the movie maybe baby
will be like going into like buy it I
don't know because they do that on porn
sites all the time they'll be like
streaming and if they're like right
before the come shot they're like you
want the full video go to this side and
I'm like no you just cheated me I'll go
to another video that has a final come
shot
[Music]
[Music]